[Musique]
alors bonsoir et merci d'être là ce soir
je vais commencer par vous dire que une
autre science est possible une autre
science est possible en afrique une
autre science est possible au bénin
alors impropre à priori je dois stimuler
votre curiosité et moi je veux plus de
la choqué votre curiosité alors en 2015
l'unesco disait de l'afrique je vais
paraphraser un pour un sens plus
dramatique
il est ce que disait ce continent et un
vide scientifique
comprenez c'est le vide scientifique ça
dit il rien quoi rien à dire merci alors
ça ça même un paradoxe que moi je
n'arrive pas à comprendre et que vous
allez peut-être m'expliquer ce que sur
notre continent
j'ai fait quelques petites rues juchés
sur wikipédia j'ai vu quoi il ya plus de
1000 ouais mais l'université située aux
riches ils sont deux formations de trucs
intéressants comme ça où des gens
produisent du savoir ça c'est super mais
toujours 2015 les sk encore dit bah ce
continent avec ces mails universités ces
mails institut de recherché pour le
reste il produit moins de 3% de tous
ceux qui produisent que c'était comme
production scientifique c'est facile
vous comprenez c'est que tout ce qu'il y
a suscité comme un attique scientifique
tes fiches de résultats de richy site ou
non en afrique on produit moins de 3%
c'est quoi waouh quand je commence à
l'université on m'a dit des gens qui
sont docteurs dézoner et docteur c'est
des docteurs en fait je dis les
d'obtenir le dos de la cedh et donc ils
font quoi ils font de la recherche d'un
corps mais a priori quand tu fais de la
richesse
on est censé voir les output les autres
outils sont où on ne les voit pas et
c'est sûrement la chose la plus bizarre
qu'on arrive pas expliqué ce grand
paradoxe ce grand gars qui hésite un peu
nombre d'instituts de recherche
d'universités et production scientifique
et en ce moment donné je n'épouse pas se
poser une question est ce que ça ce
problème est ce que ça veut dire que sur
le continent africain
on ne produit pas du contenu on ne
produit pas de la recherche on ne publie
pas d'un titre scientifique est ce que
c'est ce que ça veut dire
pas forcément alors là pas forcément on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y à quoi
beaucoup de personnes beaucoup
d'institutions de recherche
beaucoup d'enseignants beaucoup de
chercheurs qui produisent effectivement
des contenus il faut ça tout le temps
mais les contenus on ne les voit pas où
je suis le web scientifique
pourquoi un cercle vicieux alors il ya
en afrique un gros sac vicieux qui s'est
construit autour de la publication
scientifique et de production
scientifique ce qui empêche nos contenus
nos recherches
les résultats de nos richesses d'être
visible sur le web alors comment ça se
passe
il ya une grosse grosse institution qui
s'appelle web style qui recense qui est
jean le gendarme de la production
scientifique dans le monde alors le web
os ainsi les gens le statisticien et des
articles scientifiques
une renaissance dans les revues les
universités la différence
les différents contenus les différents
articles sont produits et à base de safe
un classement présents pour le décider
de quoi
mais jean est
la première je prends l'exemple les
cités de cotonou est la deuxième voie là
il fait ce classement là mais le
problème c'est qu'en afrique est un gros
sac vicieux qui s'est construit autour
de cette stratégie et qui fait quoi où
être visible dans le web of science
il faut publier dans une revue ou un
grand revue veut gommer des billets une
revue vraiment qui a des moyens pour
financer les chercheurs qui a des moyens
pour la recherche effectuée visible sur
internet et qui est également des moyens
pour la diffuser alors il se fait qu'en
afrique qu'au bénin et dans tous les
autres pays vraiment dans tous les
autres pays les enseignants les
chercheurs les docteurs et tout le reste
donc peut-être pas connaissance de ces
grandes revues là donc ils produisent
les articles soit ils ne les publient
pas où il est plus bus y eut des sortes
de rejoue dès sorte de plateforme en
ligne qui sont essentielle des revues
ces publications ne sont pas visibles
elles ne sont pas recensés dans le web
of 16 le web os est dit que l'afrique ne
produit rien et ça continue donc un
modèle capitaliste ne favorise pas et ça
continue une boucle qui continue tu
continues qui continue qui font tuer
alors ce moment donné je dis encore pose
une mon titre au début je l'avais
formulé comme une autre science est
possible mais affirme que je suis venu
là je me suis dit non une sens n'est pas
possible
une autre science est nécessaire là j'ai
encore dit non non je bannis sur une
autre science est obligatoire pour nous
pour nous africains pour nos chercheurs
ou enseignants aux touristes qui
produisons du contenu en afrique une
autre science est obligatoire on va
trouver un nouveau moyen de rab repenser
la science nous repenser la manière dans
le diffusion de contenu en lui de
repasser la khaled nous mettons notre
production visible sur le web
scientifique alors il ya une petite
citation que j'aime bien
qui dit open this is just fine donne
rights la science ouverte c'est la
semence rien fait alors
encore là je dispose je suis quelques
questions que vous vous posez tous
ouais mais bon produit pas du contenu en
afrique d'accord mais ça c'est pas mon
problème
jobs le matin je vais bien le choix la
fin du mois je perçois mon salaire je
fais mes couches d'accord à les anciens
de produits soit du contenu changerait
quoi
ben je veux vous dire que il se fait que
c'est votre argent
c'est l'argent du contribuable c'est
vraiment l'argent du contribuable qui
est utilisé pour financer les instituts
de recherche qui est utilisé pour
financiers des différents fonds ou des
différents craintes qui sont donnés ou
chercher à profiter des richesses chuté
de suivi spécifiques
mais ces messieurs on va pas dit ces
messieurs il utilise cet argent
elles produisent ce contenu qui est
d'ailleurs très bon produit vraiment de
la boyne richesse en afrique qui est
très bon mais ce contenu
soit on ne le met pas en ligne ou soit
pour le maire des endroits où ils sont
inaccessibles ou ceux pour qui les a
produits
alors imaginez un étudiant qui commence
lui restait un an deux ans en deuxième
année il veut écrire un document il va
sur une revue il veut télécharger le
document lui dit manga je paye 40 go là
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi en
tant qu'étudiant je vais trouver bizarre
pas parce que je ne peux pas le faire
mais je me demande de payer pour avoir
de 2,2 du contenu geste plus vraiment le
cas par exemple des livres qui se
vendent les romans qui se vend que c'est
toute notre histoire du contenu
scientifique qui a été produit par des
chercheurs pour moi mais on me demande
de pays pour les avoir ben a priori je
vais dire non alors c'est pour ça que je
dis qu'une autre science est obligatoire
alors maintenant qu'on a vu le pourquoi
on va voir le roman qu est ce qu une
autre science est possible les cissé est
obligatoire pour nom
je suis très très très très content de
toutes les personnes qui sont passés
avant moi parce que je vais me baser sur
différentes expériences que vous montrez
aux mains est ce qu'une autre science
est possible nécessaire et obligatoire
alors je vais commencer par votre chaise
organisateurs du tennis ou ce qu'ils ont
accumulé comme expérience en organisant
le tennis c'est du savoir et de la
connaissance
vous dites que peut-être je n'ai rien du
tout mais vous n'imaginez pas à quel
point les gens ont besoin du cette
reconnaissance-là l'organisation de
tennis dans la plupart de mes écrits
quand je vous écris connaissances
scientifiques
je mets toujours scientifiques entre
deux griffes vous dit que scientifique
d'accord mais il faut regarder
correctement ce qu'ils ont fait là les
crs qui sont accumulés les différents
dossiers qu'ils ont reçu c'est de la
connaissance scientifique
le monsieur le rat qui a une expérience
aux états unis sur comment sans sortie
possible c'est de la connaissance
le lait documents guides produits c'est
celle de la connaissance mais
l'expérience qu'il a eu aussi la manie
qu'il a eue de les surmonter ça aussi
c'est de la connaissance
il peut être utilisé et qu'il va au lit
vise d'ailleurs bien alors la
pharmacienne qui a compris quelque chose
qui a compris pour les 4-10 solaire pour
les médias le régler chaque processus là
c'est de la connaissance et je vous en
suis qu il y a des gens si c'est elle
qui ont besoin de cette reconnaissance
alors on peut déjà commencer comme ça
allait mettre à les rendre visibles à
rendre cette ce type de connaissances
l'invisible je pense que ça ne coûte
rien et un autre pharmacien de décret
quoi quelques lits ou même de faire un
diktat de prendre un nid de la fournée
de jeux d'hier c'était comme ça comme ça
comme ça et c'est comme ça maintenant
elle dépose ses de la connaissance ou
quelqu'un qui en a besoin
alors je vais terminer en disant que en
ce qui concerne tout richir chercheurs
docteurs et tout eux ils ont d'autres
moyens de rendre les connaissances
visible sans la rendre inaccessible pour
ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin
c'est pour ça que je disais que open 6 2
6 2
wait non juste adopter cette attitude
empêche d'être open en leur rendant leur
connaissance libre
c'est bien de produits du savoir mais
c'est bien aussi de s'assurer que je
savoie qui a été produit pour à ses
billets à des personnes qui sont
vraiment dans le besoin
du coup c'est bien mieux pour nous pour
toute la communauté pour notre argent
qu'on dépense ou le savoir dans mon a
besoin pour le développement dont a
besoin que c'est qu'on est sans cela
soit libre bah ça ne va pas a priori le
goûter quelque chose de publier les
actes de vengeance ou les contributions
scientifiques ou le résultat du riche si
on revit en libre accès plus que que ce
une revue totalement fermé où ils vont
demander à des étudiants de payer 40 50
60 100 dollars pour acquérir un article
2000 boutoir niveau iv bill buhr alors
merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]